ahoy TV lovers I'm your captain and host
Liana Galera and I like to welcome you
to ship worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating the best couples on TV and
this week ship is the gold standard
that's right today we're talking all
about the flashes Barry Allen and iris
West
aka West Allen not only will I be
flashing back to how this super couple
first sped on to our screens
I'll also be running through all of West
Allen's best naughty or nice scenes plus
your hearts gonna be racing because I
have an exclusive interview with Grant
Gustin
and Candice Patton yep together talking
all about why they think iris and Barry
are a perfect pair they're kind of just
like an ideal couple
basically this episode of ship are thee
is a love letter to the West Allen
fandom and I hope this episode is going
to make you happier than drunk Barry now
it's time to batten down the hatches and
move full speed ahead because a tidal
wave of romance is headed your way Barry
Allen's heroic backstory may have
started with tragedy you know due to the
fact that his mom was killed by the
reverse-flash and then his father was
framed for her murder and sent to prison
but when Joe West took him in young
Barry found his second family and the
love of his life
iris West there is nothing that I want
more than for you to meet the right
person that
he loves and adores you for the amazing
guy that you are Barry may have been the
one with his heart on his sleeve when it
came to his feelings for iris but she
was the one waiting by his bedside as he
became the fastest man alive we knew
that these Canon cuties were destined to
be together it just took a little longer
than expected normally at this point and
ship worthy I'd like to quickly recap
how a couple got to their first kiss
that things aren't that simple for West
Allen why well because this
time-traveling twosome has had anywhere
from four to six first kisses I find
that hard to believe their very first
speedster smooch happened in episode 115
just as Barry was about to take down a
powerful weather controlling Mehta iris
finally confessed that she has feelings
for him
[Music]
Oh unfortunately the beginning of
west-allen was quickly put on pause as
Barry ran back and forth his speed was a
little too fast and he took his first
trip back in time which ultimately
erased that kiss from existence their
next first kiss took place in the season
2 finale while Barry was still reeling
from the fact that zoom had murdered his
father
iris stepped outside to confess her
feelings again and encouraged him to do
whatever it takes to mend his broken
heart whatever you need to do
do it
and when you get back I'll be here
[Music]
but that one was also erased why well
because Barry took irises advice to the
extreme and you ran back in time and
stopped reverse-flash from ever killing
his mom and thus creating an alternate
timeline called flashpoint even though
he and iris never lived together in this
new timeline she was still the girl of
his dreams
but Barry reluctantly realized that
change in the past was a big mistake it
was time for flashpoint to end well I
know when things change back but once
again that kiss was also erased because
Barry set the original timeline more or
less back on track after flashpoint and
then it finally happened after three lip
locks that were lost in time Barry and
iris reconnected on the porch and 3:02
for another heart-to-heart wherever you
go you'll always be Barry and always be
iris and we always find each other and
this time they finally shared their
first kiss oh oh and okay if we're
really getting technical here there were
also two more first kisses for Barry
that time in season two when Barry
traveled into the multiverse and kissed
earth to Iris and in episode 3 21 when
Barry had amnesia and kissed iris for
the first time again so technically
there have been up to six first kisses
for the super couple but I'm personally
sticking with four now that we've
watched their first pucker ups over and
over and over again let's take a look
back at this couple's sweetest and
studious scenes in naughty or nice all
right guys racing into some of West
Dawn's nicest moments like that
legendary moment in the pilot when iris
saw Barry for the first time after he
woke up from his coma the way she looked
at him and left into his arms was this
couple's first truly swim worthy moment
now as the show continued and iris
discovered the shocking truth
Barry was patiently impatient to change
their dynamic from lifelong friends to
full-fledged couple all I know is
you're everything to me and you always
have been
and the sound of your voice will always
bring me home and once west-allen
finally got on track very quickly and
adorably brought them to the next step
with this sweet Christmas surprise the
first thing I want to see when I wake up
the last thing and it was in that very
loft were Barry then proposed to Iris
twice once with a dreamy array of
flowers and candles and then a second
time with a one-of-a-kind song that has
been stuck in my head since I heard it
but I want you in it every
me a new virus West will you marry me
now we've had epic reunions some amazing
pep talks not lightning-rod and of
course plenty of city saving cuddles
they even make a perfect pair when they
switch places no iris but their weddings
yes I said weddings because repeats of
big moments tends to be a west-allen
trend will always have a special place
in my shipper heart even if they did
have to share it mm-hmm more on that
later I'm not bitter as for those
naughty scenes well I'm sad to say we
haven't had nearly as many sultry scenes
as we deserve but these early couch
canoodle since season 3 showed off their
insane chemistry even if it was
interrupted we were treated to quite a
few more heated moments once Barry and
iris moved in together this is the third
night no no this after two dancing but I
think my all-time favorite West Allen
scene that's a perfect blend of naughty
and nice is when Barry created the most
perfect morning of all time for iris
which then led to a sultry breakfast in
bed can you actually do this yes Jill I
know that all of you gold-standard
shippers out there have been asking for
a joint interview between Grant Gustin
and Candice Patton for a long long time
so I made it my mission to make this
happen for you thank you for saving my
life after I sat down with the full cast
of the flash at comic-con I was able to
feel a few extra minutes with just grant
and Candice for an exclusive checked so
let's race back in time and take a look
at what they told me
thank you so much for taking time out of
your crazy comic-con schedule to sit
down and chat with me for ship worthy we
love west-allen
so much so I'm just curious to know what
has it been like for you guys bring this
couple to life it's been easy I find
working with Grant very easy the work
when we're together especially scenes
alone just comes very naturally has a
fluidity to it no I don't know it's
probably one of the bigger joys for me
working on this show was doing those
scenes it's good because it's like
obviously an iconic couple but I feel
like kind of from the very beginning
we've like each see like she's her own
version of iris and I'm own version of
Barry so as a couple I mean it's a very
different version of iris and Barry from
the comics I think the trajectory of the
relationship was different so it's been
grateful what do you think it is about
Barry and iris together that has
resonated so strongly with the fandom
they're so steadfast I mean no matter
what yeah yeah since childhood and I
think there's something really endearing
about that everyone wants that everyone
wants a relationship of someone that you
can count on and trust and to tell you
the truth and I feel like Barry and iris
have that so they're kind of just like
an ideal couple
and we're really different so I feel we
can bring like as we are really I feel
like we both just bring really different
things the relationship hey Allen what
has gotten into you being with you makes
me want to do things like this you know
I love the couples so much and I talk to
both of you about this off screen that I
really wanted our west-allen wedding
what do you think the chances are that
we could ever get flashbacks to their
reception or maybe a valid renewal or
something like that very slim I would
say a vow renewal is more likely it like
a later season though or something or I
don't know yeah I would like to see
something like something yeah I know it
bothered a lot of people that they
didn't get their official yeah Barry and
iris another shoes oh yeah so yeah
that'd be really nice actually would be
cool yeah lastly what is your favorite
thing about Barry and iris
hmm that's so like it's like like you
know like what's your favorite color
yeah yeah I'm knowing like they're talks
which sounds so cheesy but I love their
loft I love their law yeah totally
that's it actually I like your taste in
furnishings
Furniture Furniture Furniture overall I
could talk for hours about why I adore
very and iris so much as a couple but
I'm gonna take a cue from Barry and keep
this quick above all I love that West
Allen is a team you are not the flash
Barry
we are they've had six first kisses for
weddings and two proposals oh and not to
mention one iconic love story and no
matter what speed bumps are in their way
they always run back to each other one
is just a little faster than the other
[Music]
and there you have it I hope you thought
that this west-allen
episode of ship worthy was worth the
wait so if you enjoyed this then please
give this video a like and then don't
forget to hit the comments or chat with
me on Twitter to tell me your favorite
naughty or nice west-allen scenes then
cast your nominations for which other
couples I should feature on future
episodes of ship worthy thanks so much
for watching you guys and until next
time
bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]